hello old friend
oh boy welcome to the mediator you don't
be reporting on an injury looks like the
horse will be out indefinitely
I've seen that mark before yes it's hand
checking know since the horse injury my
birds from Toronto have become useless
they're just repeating the same things
over and over
well whatever jizz seemed to spread
train we've got to get the cream city
Yanis come quickly we're being attacked
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to a very special
edition of inside the realm dears
masters of the media tell I now present
the audition of SIRT Wayne Wade for
consideration of press credentials today
sir Duane will be reporting on the
horse's injury Duane how will this
affect house rafters it's bad it's it's
very bad um - shame he was there glue
guy no more than over wait wait wait I'm
not done the reason it's bad is because
Sir Jordan and the entire dream team are
back and they're going to destroy our
realm one house at a time
what are you doing just wrap it up
listen no Jordan slander here but he's
too old father time is undefeated I must
be real
the only return shocks making is to the
buffet table yes but that's the thing
they're all back in their primes this is
demonstrably preposterous
how could that possibly be conceivable
the sole box Oh
hooey my report ensure that the soul box
was smashed in bostonia yeah that was a
tap nineteen moment in bostonia
basketball history and therefore
basketball history the soul box power is
not in the box it's in the shards it was
just a normal fault
no the shards the fragments of the
shattered soul box
they're made from the wood of Val makers
original peach baskets hickory Georgian
hardwood it's G H Oh Jordan must have
gotten the shots in the terry rozier
trade that's why he paid so much
Oh hui Brian I call shenanigans where's
your proof
mama there goes that man horse how's
this for evidence who is that
it's Wally Szczerbiak no it can't be why
not because I'm Wally Szczerbiak I think
that's Tom Gugliotta no I'm Tom
Gugliotta no you're not you're Bobby's
Sora all right yeah it's Christian
Laettner so you're telling me the dream
team is back I mean I don't see the
problem this is a story at a century yes
but it would be the last story sir
Jordan seeks to permanently end the
debate to prove he is the goat of goats
she's coming for me no Paul truth if
anyone he's coming for LeBron hey it's
moppet the people of every city he
conquers are turned into mindless
nostalgic s-- with no passion for the
modern game Toronto is already gone well
as is me love walkie also Detroit and
Chicago is all right though you know we
need to form a kin war it's no use
there's not a house in this realm that
could beat the dream team you're right
that's why we've got to build one ladies
and gentlemen of the media tell we're
going to need your all run ballots a
little early this year
thank you everyone for being here at
this emergency realm all hands by now
you should all be familiar with the
threat facing our realm so without
further ado I will announce the members
of the super super house hereby known as
the knights of the round ball as
selected by the Masters of the media del
bloody serious blog board as president
of the Knights killed I think this
decision should be made by us the
Knights of the realm I don't know if
that's a wise idea this is not the time
of your this is the era of knights
empowerment let us vote or we shall
fight your battles ok fine
but please take this seriously ok that's
another vote for Jamal Crawford she's
shot us with another vote for Mello
another vote for Vince Carter who's 42
cool actually 43 now look all three
Plumlee's and Jamal Crawford again look
if you're not going to take this serious
I took it seriously you voted for Allen
Iverson he cannot even play anymore how
I gonna disrespect Iverson like that one
of you even voted for Michael Jordan hey
so Jordan was unstoppable of this prime
yes we know that's the whole point we
have to defeat him well good luck with
that maybe we should let the fatlings
vote no okay listen we experimented with
letting the foundlings vote for the
final roster spots let's just say it was
a mistake well who do they pick oh it's
okay buddy you still my little goat and
while we all agree we love taco we can
also all agree we do not want taco
defending the realm against the dream
Jim so you're just gonna disrespect
talker like that Wow
okay taco do you want to go against the
dream team not particularly right thank
you you may sit down absolutely good
listen this is not just any battle if we
lose our Fanning's will desert us our
economy will screech to a halt and our
society which is solely based on
interest in basketball will crumble
around us before you know it we'll be on
the verge of extinction like the ice
peoples of our Kenya so here are the
official media delft selections for the
knights of the round ball King James sir
Waddell Stefan carry the second Sir
Anthony Davis Sir James Hardin sir Kawhi
Leonard Jason Tatum sir Rudy Gobert sir
Lucca Don Cheech sir Dame Lillard and
Sir Gerald beets and replacements for
the injured Kevin of Durant and the
vanquished Yanis attenti combo will be
nikola yogic yeah house Nuggets we did
it and finally at point guard the
undersized and often controversial but
incredibly savvy so Chris Paul are you
kidding me I know many of you are
unhappy and feeling a sense of snobbery
so where is this big battle supposed to
take place
I say we draw them into the mountains
the Denver Highlands Denver I think we
should all fight for the purple and gold
I mean what better place for such a
grand super house I could never wear
those colors we should fight for Houston
no house better represents the modern
game the cutting edge of battle strategy
no there's no way that I'm doing that
we're not going to any of those places
the location of the battle has already
been chosen it will take place at a
house that everyone can agree on a place
where we can minimize collateral because
the Fanning's
are sparse and already stuck in the past
a house with a history of defense but
most importantly a place whose market
viability I'm interested in testing
tonight we ride
for Seattle
[Music]
you
[Music]